j'ai trente hectares et le moment de
cinq mois c'est assez vrai mais tu vois
ce goal c'est mon gros coup la vieille
sa bicoque pourri c'est moi qui m'en
occupais à décamper non
non c'est pas moi qui suis fort c'est
vous qui êtes nuls
le plus grand chose dans ton vieux
qu'une un carabosse ailleurs il est bon
sur lui
ça tue ma mère soit asséché
qu'est ce qu'il fout le bordel pour
appeler la police il fait chaud beaucoup
trop chou bois pour téléphoner mais il
est périmé droit qu'aux quoi comme trous
dans les métros 30 pour la gym sachez
que tu me fais comme ça chez
adam romney maintenant c'est plus
carabosse et matam un ça va pas me
laisser comme ça tout le temps lui
il a dit que cela coûte que coûte
et combien de temps que vous l'avez pas
fait la coupe vous avez une idée ni t il
et des doudous tout y est
non
tu ne sortiras pas quoi
c'est pas moi c'est lourd
je veux pas mourir sur jean pierre
françois